Bob: Thanks for joining, everybody. Um...
Person: My name is Markiplier/
Bob: He said the Markiplier thing.
Mark: Did he say it? Did he say the Markiplier thing? / Bob: He did, he did.
Mark: No way! Yeah, I got- I got nothing going on.
I just have people...
doing ME / Person: Hello, everybody, my name is Markiplier.
Mark: All right, I'll give you one good old... All right, here we go! Hello, everybody, my name is Markiplier! / People: *Shrieks*...Oh, he did it... Hi...
Mark: I did the thing! I did the thing, guys! Yeah, you're welcome.
Jack: Voice chat muted. / Wade: Look at the foggy map! / Mark: Oh, my God, it's so foggy!
Bob: Soo, we're in a good position- / Jack: Kameshki! Kameshki! / Bob: Yeah, we're going to actually go to Kameshki. / Mark: Kameshki?
Mark: Okay. / Wade: Okay. / Jack: It's a NEW town! / Bob: As soon as you can jump, go jump and go north. / Jack: I'm spamming F.
Bob: Spam F right now; you'll jump out. / Mark: Oh, boy! / Bob: Fly north.
Bob: It's a pretty flar flight, so you might have to aim up. / Mark: It's a pretty 'FLAR' flight? Pfft.
Bob: IT'S A PRETTY FLAR FLIGHT! / Mark: Pretty flar flight. / Jack: IT'S A FLAR FLIGHT! YOU'LL GET THERE! / Bob: All right, I see two zambies following us. / Jack: Yep. / Mark: That's good...
Jack: Think you're CLEVER, huh?! / Bob: Wade... Wade, watch out, that's twice as many as you can handle.
Wade: Hey! / Jack: *Laughing* /Wade: Hey, ONE time! / Mark: *Laughing*
Wade: I won this mode, thank you! / Jack: *Still laughing* / Bob: Wade, I hate to tell you this... but your mic is kind of crackly for me. / Jack: *Laughing*
Wade: Are you kidding me? / Bob: I'm not joking. / Mark: No, you're fine! You're fine!... Maybe, I don't know. / Bob: I don't want to listen to that shit this whole time!
Wade: Is that better? No! / Bob: No! It's so much worse! *laughing* / Wade: How about now?
Bob: Noo *laughing* / Wade: No?
*Gunshots* Bob: We- Someone get in that- Okay. / Jack: Did you get him? / Wade: Oh, Frivva! Did you want to say HELLO RIGHT OFF THE BAT!? / Mark: *Winces* / Bob: Wow. / Jack: Okay.
Mark: Wade mad! Scury! / Jack: Wade issues! / Mark: *Chuckles* Wade emotional problems that need to work out without aggression!
Wade: *Laughs* / Jack: Wade is smell. / Mark: *Laughs*
Bob: Wow. That's just rude, guys.
Wade: You guys have a problem with Wade? / Mark: NOO! / Bob: I don't have a problem with Wade. / Mark: WADE! NEVER!
*Laughter* Bob: What is- what is that voice? / Jack: He's giggling like a little girl! / Bob: What is that voice!? / Mark: I'm Wade! Guys, you kn- / Bob: NoOoO... / Mark: I'm very clearly Wade. Duh!
Bob: No problem with WaAaAade. / Mark: *Laughs* We nEvEr have pRoBlEm!
Bob: It sounds like, when you talk like that, that you DO have a problem *laughs* with Wade. I just feel like I'm sensing some sarcasm or something, like...
Jack: That's all on you, man! Jeez!
Mark: Yeah, yeah, I can't help it if YOU'RE hearing that. / *Sigh* Bob: So, where's Wade? / Wade: Better? Do I sound better?
Mark: Ah! / All: Yeah! / Bob: That sounds good! / Mark: WaDe SoUnDs ReAl GoOd! / Wade: I'm recording audio again! / Jack: WADE BETTER! / Mark: *Laughs*
Mark: Is ThIs BeTtEr, GuYs?? / Wade: *coughs & laughs* GoOd!
*Everyone laughing* Bob: Oh, this has been looted! FuUuUu / Jack: Hey! No- no problem! And do keep in mind, um, I will treat you nicely. / Mark: You said dookie. / Wade: I appreciate that!
Jack: Ha! Dookie in mine! / Bob: Sick, bro. / Mark: *Awkward chuckling*
Bob: In the STREET! STREET! / Wade: Oh! Zombie! Chased it down. / Jack: Guys... / Bob: What the fuck?!
Wade: It's down. / Bob: I'm awful! :( / Mark: Well, yeah. You just realizing this now? / Bob: Hey, zombie friend.
Mark: Oh! look out behind you!! / Bob: *Screams* It's right beside me! / Mark: Look out, Bob! Bob! *Jack laughs*
Person: Oh, God! Please don't do it! / Jack: Wait. So, are we allowed to use M16's and shit? / Bob: Yeah, anything that spawns is allowed. I try to balance it so that it's- / Mark: You need a first-aid kit?
Mark: I got a first-aid kit, here. / Bob: I've got one. Can you watch me for a second while I use it? / Mark: Yeah, I got your back. / Jack: We should go. We have REALLY far to run. / Mark: Uh, oh. / Bob: We're going to die to the circle, aren't we?
Mark: NoOoO- We are.
Wade: I feel like everyone took off running. I probably should follow suit. / Mark: Yeah, you probably should. / Jack: Put away that weapon. / Bob: The fog does make it a bit harder to find stuff.
Mark: How do I put away the weapon again? I forgot. / Bob: X. / Mark: X! Excellent!
Jack: Heh, X marks the spot! / Wade: Do you guys smell that? / Mark: X is the letter!
Jack: X is going to give to you! / Mark: X Is GoInG To GiVe It To YoU!
Mark: You think you can get it on your own? You can't! It would be really pathetic of us to die to the blue.
*Bob laughs nervously* Mark: Just throwing that out there. / Wade: It would be very Us.
Bob: It would be not the best reflection on us as human beings to die to the circle. -*Jack laughs*- I have a uaz! *Russian accent begins* Up and zoom! Up and zoom!
Jack: Up and zooooooom! / Bob: *Normal voice again* I'm going to drive straight at you at full speed, Mark.
Mark: Perfect. Ah, I saw a GIF of someone going under it, so I'm going to do that.
Mark: No! I don't want to drive it. Okay, there we go. / Jack: Sick! / Mark: Ah! That is blue! How'd that get here so quickly!? Hoo!!!
Jack: Oh, God, that's blue! / Wade: Man! / Mark: Oh, my goodness! / Bob: Hey, dumbasses, you want a ride?
Jack: Yes, yes, I want a zoom! / Bob: All right, well, Wade... We're fucking out of here. / Wade: Nooooo :(
Jack: Get in, bitches, we're going shopping! / Wade: I'm so close! :(
Wade: :'( / Bob: Come here, man! Come on! / Wade: I'm trying! / Mark: Jesus.
All: All right! :D / Bob: Time to go! / Mark: Here we go!
Jack: *Singing* What is love? *Wade joins in* Baby, don't hurt me...  no more! Don't hurt me... no more!
Mark: Ow, ow, ow...
Mark: Bob, it would be even more embarrassing if we got this vehicle and then you crashed and then we died to the blue. / Bob: No, it's fine.
Everyone: *beat boxing badly* unsk unsk usk unsk unsk
Mark: ooh ooh ooh ooh
Jack: Woooh off road!
Bob: i thought i was about to drive us off a cliff- we good
Jack: *in southern accent*  i'm gonna keep my peepers open for that there Zambies
Mark: *in southern acent* I can't see nothing there's foooog
Jack: * in accent* There's some sorta thick aiirr
Mark: *Laughs*
Wade: if you know what we mean / Bob: look out for some zombies
Jack: OH right infront of us!
Bob: Where? / Mark:Huh?
Jack: to the left / Wade: do you hear gunshots? / Mark: That's not right infront of us
Bob: do you hear another vehicle?
Mark: Oh them! / Bob: oh them
Jack: hehe are you scared!
Bob: Lets get out and kill these bitches
Wade: err circle's on its way  / Mark: Perfect idea!
Mark: there is one crawling right here. You think you can hide! NO!
Bob: ooohhhh mark / Jack: get em get em
Mark: It's too late for you!
Wade: Oh! Behind you!
Mark: oh oh / Bob: alright lets go
Jack: BLUE BLUE BLUE BLUE BLUE!
Mark: oh ah eh oh ooh
Mark: Wait! / Bob: Mark that's the wrong car!
Mark: We were in that other one! *nearly gets run over* AGH!
Bob: i thought we were taking two! *everyone laughing*
Mark: Jesus Christ! i'm the only one to have memory around here
*still laughing*
Bob: I thought we were- i said lets take two
Wade: yeah! that's why i hopped in the other one!
Mark: well then why did three of you get in  one and me get in- no i dont think you said that
Mark: i think you're just making me sound stupid! / Jack: yeah i don't think you said that either!
Wade: well i heard you Bob
Jack: I just ran to the nearest one
Anyway This one was full of gas so this was a good choice, yeah
Yeah, all right. We're gonna stop here and heal up for a sec. Okay. I see zombies at
Northeast where Oh
Between the hay bales that I'm running right towards he's writing, but twixt them yeah that big stack
yeah he's got fat stacks! / Mark: mmhh
There's a building over there you want to go lookee at thatee, yeah why arent we doing this?
i dunno we are following Bob's lead hey, we're still alive. I'm not I didn't say lead like
Following Bob's lead. You know I wasn't waiting it up
no no no no! that was I was just saying as a fact we were following your lead- OH THERE'S  A ZOMBIE. I'm coming to help
*Zombie wail* That sounds bad
There's a couple well that one went in the building for some reason good job guys. *Zombie wail*
There's more. Yeah. There's more out by mark. Where's one up on the hill to the north
I say I've just been seeing mark. Oh hey, there's a bunch of ammo down here. Oh, I feel like a big man
No, and I have no time to heal now. Oh, why is Wade driving? Let's do this. We're we're survivors
Look at us
i have very low health ok Wade
Jack: murder apartments, Murder apartments
That sounds bad
did you put a marker on them? Is that green yeah? I don't like the way that sounds
It's the school man you've been there before yeah, but I you never described it that way before just cuz we've been there
nah its the murder apartments-  like if we go to Grandma's house, and then we go back and you suddenly call it murder grandma
I'm gonna be a little worried about it. You know what I mean
what do you mean. im just saying. i feel like thats bad naming technique. its murder-ma's. murder-ma's
Yeah, that's even worse
Murder me ma murder me ma murder me ma
wouldnt it just be grandma's murder house
oh we have broken doors here We probably shouldn't split up OHH Zombies right here at 15 behind you mark
Hmm all right just stay stay as a group
Watch your watch, or sixes. Let's go. Let's just start clearing these buildings out
Okay, i downed that zombie, but he didn't die you didn't die all the way all right. I'll go I'll go
I'm gonna go straight to the top of this one. Oh I hear him. They're talking. They're in this
They're in here there are zombies in here. I heard voices
Turn that on
They see us
Trying to come in the front door here okay realize that we can hear everything
I'm gonna go circle around. I don't have their voices on shall i turn it- no mark mark. Don't get isolate. Don't get Isolated okay
Okay, you got it. You go. Oh wait wait. I know where one is
No, it's right under here
*Bob laughing*
Let's quickly
wade! behind you. Right there right there!
that was fucking funny. that was great Turning on voice god call good call
See that's why I just tolerate I still here don't give us a hug did they fuck up our Jeep oh?
Shit, I hope they didn't think of that oh noooooo
guys we gotta run we gotta run
ok alright. Oh God we are never gonna make it that far!
What do you and your not optimism will find another vehicle  oh I have no heals well this gonna suck isn't it
* tense music stars in background* It's gotta be vehicles around here. I just hope they're not all totally fucked. It's a Dacia
It's not fucked get in get in get in turn only good call good call good
Call I got a motorcycle you guys go let's go
I'm dying here Mark's gonna die no. No I'm fine. Go go go. I'll live. There is a Zombo! . Oh Oh
FREE POINTS *jack laughs*
Guys I mean, I really just need to catch the blue is what I need to do
Yeah, I believe in you I believe in you my life is in your hands but i totally believe in you
aghhhhh its right there!!
MARK HOLD ON. EUGHHHHH  I'M PUSHING!!!
We can do this, ughhhh my bones
we can do this.... we can do this we can do this we can do this we can do this
oh shit no. NOOOOOO
I'm fine. I'm fine. I'm fine. I'm I'm tougher than this im tougher than this. oh fuck no
*mark goes down* *everyone* no omg  oh fuck
wait wait wait! I'M IN I'M IN
im coming. niceeee. Holy shit
Run straight back to further car okay. We should heal boost do whatever you need to do right now
Yeah, heal up fully i've only got  bandages. I see a lot of Zombies south of us
Holy shit. Everyone. Just everyone just Gatorade up. That's fuckin know what
hahahaha you can keep the ammo
I'm in the vehicle good god
man that was tense
i always forget they can fuck up the cars yeah, so tense I was inches Oh my god
has anyone got an energy drink or ssome bandage-? oh shit Zombies close quick guys get in get in get in
Jack: Shoot, shoot! Oh my god, nice shot.
Mark: Nice shot.
Jack: This is like almost final circle stuff.
Mark: Yeah
Wade: Why are we driving this?
Bob: Why are we driving? Park this, park this!
Jack: No!
Bob: We're like two feet away from the circle. Driving is just giving us away.
Park the goddamn car.
Mark: Okay, okay, okay, geez. Oof.
Wade: they'll never find us
Bob: Everyone was like, 'Get in get in!' But we're here already.
This is it.
Jack: Doors are broken here...
Bob: That's enough to kill 74 people...
Wade: Here, Jack,  I'll drop some more here.
Jack: No, it's fine. I have... [Yes, have what?]
Wade: I still have two hundred and thirty four/
Bob: We really need to start like thinning this herd. We're about to be in a position where
Bad no it's fine
We're on the good side of it for still and we just we really need to start getting some kills is the thing okay? Yep
Hunting time. oh god this tall grass is the worst this is not
Yeah, this is the worst yeah, there are 74 zombies currently in this area are at boys
Yeah, let's hunt let's head south around the circle and try and hunt a little bit. Yeah, I'm going up this hill
There's gotta be some of them. Just laying prone. Let's just let's just hunt as a pack
Try and get a lot of them. Hopefully I'm behind you like 30 or 40
Foxtrot Delta Oscar Mike, let's see anything and all I hear is wind that's terrifying and the and our voice chat is on
Christ our voice chat is on oh yeah. How how are we not hearing them? They're all together
I like what you just get close and all you hear us
myonmYONMOMOYNYOMOY
and everyone is talking. yep pretty much im terrified
This is not good
Bang bang we're gonna get to the circle, and then just get like mobbed by like 20 zombie  I'm gonna kill any zombies of people
Yeah, I can do it. Can you? no it's gonna happen
stop Freaking out fine. It's fine Wade. Everything is fine. I feel like you say that a lot
It's fine Wade, and the fact you have to say that a lot is concerning. Yeah. It's fine. Yeah, why have we seen none I?
Don't know this is awful
I am maybe they're all shaking in my chair right now the doors are broken there well
We could use this road as like our port point of the circle and a little clear space to hold
they are all just gonna be in this field
I'm watching the houses. Did you guys hear something?
No
I'm hearing maybe mumbles in the distance should we try and should we try and bait them out?
Where we should see them from?
There's some 30. I threw a smoke. Yeah, the blue is here none of them have appeared. Are you fucking kidding me right now? I?
See movement at 30 again somebody in a bush these bushes are so good for hiding in
Here, I scared him up up there good enough
oh they are getting up!  *bob laughing*
i was just shooting way out into the fiel- AAghhh Agh OH MY GOD THEY'RE DOING IT IM DOWN!
How are you down?
Because one rushed me. yet again Wade was downed by his nemesis one zombie. alright Bob
i was shooting at the one screaming
if you oh hello. oh shit
coming at you guys you guys they're all pushing. Oh my god. There are so many coming from north of us guys
alright well i helped kill one. oh my god oh my godoh my god
Holy shit, holy shit, holy shit, oh fuck oh god
ohhhhhh! well well well well aghh
God Jesus Christ this seems oh my god. Holy shit
oh my god. OH OH MY GOD THIS IS AWFUL AHHHHHAHAH - omg youre just screaming- AHHHHHHHH jesus christ
OH MY GOD HOW ARE THEY HITTING ME
Jack: Somebody's just yelling, 'For the Horde!'
HAHAHA!
Wade: Mark is all alone over here.
I'm fine. Just don't tell them that I'm here.
Jack: You should go prone... haha, and they all die to the blue xD
Wade: Oh hey, there they come...
Bob: Mark how did you get away from them?!?
Bob: [Hysterical laughing]
Wade: Not a single one chased after [Mark].
Mark: They're coming for me. They know I'm here...
[Shushing]
Mark: I think they know...
Oh no- OH OH [descent in panic]
OH GOD
Jack: RUN INTO THE BLUE!
Bob: Mark, you gotta turn right--
Mark: OH no, it's too late.
[Laughing]
Mark: Jesus Christ- they- oh my... g-good god!